[Music]
hello everyone welcome and welcome back
to the road 2000. as always my name is
caleb denby and i will be your driver on
this journey
sorry about the brief delay getting
started here tonight we had some tech
issues but we're up and running now
and i'm glad that we are because it's
going to be a very fun lecture so
if you come to the chess club often you
might have run into someone by the name
of jacob sanders who likes to play the
grab quite a bit so tonight i am going
to be showing you a refutation to the
grob gonna give you that complete
repertoire against one g4 hopefully to
get you into winning positions no matter
what white does because that's just how
bad this move one g4 is so hopefully we
can ruin jacob's day and we can make him
start playing some real chess some real
chess is the goal
so of course what is the grub grab is
one g4 by white so this is
without a doubt the single worst move
that white can play on move one even
worse than f3 because f3 at least
controls the center g4 puts a pawn on a
square where it's hanging it does not
control the center it does not help you
develop any piece aside from the bishop
on f1 which we'll see is not going to be
good enough so
i was talking to the in-person audience
a little bit before here we have one
grob fan in the audience now have you
guys faced the grab much before are you
familiar
with this opening at all
no okay so this is the type of annoying
thing that people will like do
especially on the internet when they
want to like you know be cool and beat
you with a bad opening um there are some
some real crazy people out there
jacob sanders who believe in this
opening but either way we're going to
give you a nice little
antidote to this g4 move
so
if you flip on an engine here it'll tell
you that d5 is really really good for
black and e5 is really really good for
black and i think knight c6 is really
really good for black
probably all of these moves are also
really really good for black this move
is probably really really good for black
there's a lot of things that you can do
here and just be a lot better so tonight
i wanted to show you sort of the the
quote-unquote conventional way of
playing against the grab this is i would
say the the main refutation that's
that's out there
so after g4 what you're going to want to
do is go d5 now why choose d5 over e5
well of course e5 is also a really good
move and you'll be better if you play e5
but d5 gets to the the heart of the
issues here for white so of course when
you put this pawn on g4
this pawn is hanging it is attacked and
with d5 we are threatening to capture
the pawn
so my my grub fan here what do you do
against d5
yeah bishop g2 right so this is what i
would say 90 percent of grog players are
gonna play they're going to play bishop
g2 here now why do they play bishop g2
well because if you capture this pawn
then they get to play some tricky lines
involving c4 when they're going to try
to break down your light squares and
queen b3 when they continue to try to
break down your light squares
uh that being said bishop takes g4 i
think is the best move because it takes
a pawn for nothing which is pretty
strong in the game of chess capturing a
pawn for nothing
so we are gonna look at those slightly
tricky variations today show you that
you don't need to know too much in order
to refute them and we'll see at the end
of the day in fact it is going to be a
strictly winning position for black so
bishop takes g4 is the move we're going
to be looking at now
if white sort of uh abandons the the
game plan here and just plays a normal
move like d4 well you're going to get a
very normal looking d4 opening
except that white should have a pawn on
g3 and instead of that black is just up
a clean pawn so very very good for black
what can you do here you can defend your
pawn make this bishop look dumb
let's say
you know like knight c3 or something you
develop your pieces
knight f3 you develop your pieces
e3 you develop your pieces bishop f4 go
e6 you're just up a pawn for nothing
which is pretty good in the game of
chess being up upon for nothing
so white can't really do that then if if
you're going to do that then like you're
just giving pawn odds to your opponent
for for absolutely nothing you know if
you wanted to play like that you would
go here first and then you would go here
and you would play this position which
is also like you know not at all a
problem for black by the way this is
like totally equal except just imagine
this position with it without the g pawn
that's what happens if they play the
grab and then don't try to play the
tricky line after bishop takes g4
so what is the tricky line well of
course it starts with c4 this is the
whole point of white's play here he's
saying look i drew your bishop out your
light squared bishop i've drawn it out
into the game
away from the defense of these light
squares on your queen's side now while
i've been doing that i developed my
bishop to start targeting these light
squares
and this is going to put you in a bad
way so this is by far the the main line
i would say
so what's a very natural response to
this move c4 what would you look at here
with the black pieces
okay taking it would be ambitious there
is are there are some issues here that
you have to look out for although i
think i would argue that even here black
might be better um you can give up a
full
exchange and
i think if you ask the computer it's
gonna say yeah black is black is better
um so you can't you can't take the pawn
but even more natural than that you know
we don't want to give up our rook let's
say rooks are valuable
yeah i would say c6 is the most natural
move right you're looking at this bishop
on g2 you don't want to see it land on
b7 why not play the move c6 try and
defend your pawn keep this bishop out of
the game
so what is white going to do against
that well we're going to see that
there's two main variations to look at
and that's really all all that's going
on here so i want to start with this
move c takes d5
followed by queen b3 at first glance
this attacks
two pawns
at the same time scary stuff uh how are
we gonna deal with it i don't know
uh but before we look just to tell you
next we're gonna look at this move queen
b3 without taking on d5 it is actually
going to change a few things and we'll
see why uh in in the next variations but
first we're sticking with this
takes takes queen b3
now between the d-pawn and the b-pawn
which pawn do you think is going to be
more important to black's position here
yeah definitely the d-pawn right it's
keeping this bishop out of the game it's
controlling the center this is going to
be the pawn that we want to keep now we
could keep it with e6 e6 is a perfectly
fine move here black is going to be
better after e6 that's the theme of the
lecture black is going to be better
after everything but the absolute best
way to play is with knight f6 and we'll
see why we left this pawn on e6 in just
a moment here
now again if white doesn't take on b7
we're up a g pawn for nothing so you
sort of have to continue with the point
here if you just try to play something
like d4
uh i believe we can just go queen to d7
and now everything's defended we'll
develop we'll be up a pawn for nothing
so we have to take on b7 if we're going
to say our opening makes any sense
now the rook is attacked
uh we want to defend the rook
so we develop the knight out to d7 can't
go to either of those squares so d7 will
do for now
and then if you look in the masters
database on lead chess i think this game
has been reached twice
uh yeah knight c3 was played once which
is the main move we're gonna look at i
think it's the move that makes the most
sense and d4 has been played once
so let's start with the bad move d4 so
this was played in a game between
let's see someone named nikolai vlassoff
and someone named rudolph mayesen
mayesin i believe
rudolph playing the black pieces here
and he immediately found the way to just
refute the opening for white so things
are already real real bad for white and
i mean real bad
uh so the danger here
is black has three pieces developed
and white has maybe even count the
bishop as developed and but it's not
really influencing the queen side it's
stopped up at this pawn
uh
and white's queen has gone you know pawn
hunting so as is often the case here uh
black is just
sort of winning by force against this
queen so pay attention to this tactic
because this tactic is going to become
really really important in both this
line and other lines as well so you want
to start off with this move rook to b8
now just quickly what happens if you
want to play the move
queen to c6
how does this one lose
yep simply rook c8 queen's attacks this
bishop is actually undefended on c1 and
now we begin to see the problem with not
developing your pieces uh they're not
great on the back row not great
um queen has to move you just take games
over
so you have to go to a6 or a7 let's see
what happened in the game first in the
game queen takes a7 was played
uh and then here
black is just immediately winning again
thanks to the issue with this bishop on
c1 and this is the move that i want you
to pay attention to with this queen on a
seven black can make a very clever move
to threaten to trap this queen and also
target this bishop on c1 so let's see if
you guys
have the move here how can we threaten
to trap the queen and also target this
bishop
yep simply queen to c8
of course hitting the bishop with the
threat of checkmate and what's our
second threat
yeah rook to a8 this queen has no
squares
so white is going to try to solve both
problems at the same time bishop f4
now if we play rook to a8 of course
white will play uh queen to c7 and still
be much worse probably but you know
won't be losing a queen
so what's the uh
what's the finishing blow here e5 yeah
e5 it's gonna attack this bishop cut it
off from the c7 square and maintain our
threat of rook to a8 so now if bishop e5
for example
trying to renew the defense
yeah checkmate is good checkmate is good
um
this also doesn't even work because we
can no we can't do this we do have to
play checkmate but checkmate is good
so e5 and white is in a very very bad
way and this is actually i believe how
this game continued d takes e5 was
white's choice in the game
um this does actually give the white
queen a square so rook to a8 bishop
queen to e3 is gonna be you know not
immediately losing material for white
but black found this nice finishing
tactic it's a little two mover here
bishop c5
no squares for the queen aside from one
so it moves to the square
and then of course rook to b4
attacks two things at the same time
queen to c2 is one of the only safe
squares for the queen
um
now rook takes f4 taking a piece
white takes on f6 to try and you know
keep keep the number of pieces the same
but now we take f2
and things things are bad things are bad
king d1 rip d4 knight d2
castles
and this game does not last much longer
uh bishop takes on g1
why doesn't white recapture this i think
uh some something to do with this is
probably why
and it's it's just over it's just over
for white it's just over
um
yeah
we can we can see the rest of the moves
but uh white went ahead and resigned
here because all of the pieces are
hanging
takes and takes will be played next
so
not too bad not too bad um by move 8 in
this game
the evaluation was -7 with this nice
tactic queen to c8 so this queen c8 move
is a really useful tactic to have in
mind especially when white goes pawn
hunting with with queen takes a7
now white of course does have a better
move here in the form of queen to a6 but
uh the ideas here for black are going to
look pretty uh pretty familiar we're
actually just going to go e5 again
and again we can make use of the fact
that this queen is is very very horribly
placed if you go d e5 you're going to
play knight c5 and your queen is all but
trapped
go to a3 or c6
you go to c6
now you actually are trapped that's a
free queen for me if you go to a3
uh
amongst other things go knight e4 can
actually play this really nasty looking
move knight to b3
attacking the queen attacking the rook
queen takes knight is met with rook
takes queen
and it's uh you're busted you're just
busted
check again will be blocked and you have
all the same problems as before
black totally totally winning so queen
a6 also not going to be good enough so
this move d4 i think just loses sort of
on the spot it's very bad for for white
it's like minus four
uh so this move knight c3 is a little
bit of a better try in our quote-unquote
main line here
so what's the point of knight c3 uh well
if we try the same thing which we
actually are
then you'll see that at the end of the
day we can go e5 here still
um
if we go queen to c8
trying to do something similar notice
that white has not blocked his path off
uh along this diagonal and in addition
we don't have any threats against c1
thanks to this nice move knight c3
on top of that white is making some
threats against our d5 pawn
so here if you don't want to know
anything you can actually play e6 and be
slightly better just defending your
center then next you're going to develop
your pieces and you can be slightly
better but we want to win we want to
refute the grab and so we're going to go
e5 here just
trying to take over the center
completely
and this is going to put whites in a
very tough spot
so if you don't take on d5 here then
again sort of what are you doing with
your pieces i'm just going to continue
with bishop to c5 and you again will
will have a very very bad position so
knight takes d5 is the only move that
really makes sense uh we can take that
guy bishop takes d5 now the point of e5
is to come out with bishop c5 and we
have all our pieces in the game
basically while white is still still
struggling
so queen to a4
does attack our bishop don't hang that
guy so we'll come back
now after knight to f3
we can actually castle here
and castles makes a threat so what
happens if white castles what was
black's threat with the move uh kingside
castles
yeah just simple tactics right just
simple tactics knight b6
all the things are attacked
i'll take your guy nothing you can do
about it
um
so
white doesn't have time to castles uh to
castle is the point
and unfortunately for white there's
still very few squares where this queen
can move to and not get captured so you
could go back to d1 but then you've
moved your queen all the way back to d1
and
again you are in a lot of trouble so
queen to h4 is a little bit more active
which is really the only move to keep
weight in the game
and if we do a quick engine check
okay queen h4 is minus 3.7 it's also
white's best move so pretty unfortunate
uh pretty unfortunate
so we're gonna look at queen h4 bishop
back to e7 of course we don't want to
trade the queens our opponent is missing
a g pawn and their king is going to be
weak we go bishop e7 queen g3
this attacks our pawn we actually do
want to keep our e5 pawn here so we'll
go bishop f6
just defending and again pretty much on
every turn here black can play a number
of alternatives and at worst be slightly
better so if you're worried you're gonna
mess this up
uh you might but then you'll still be
slightly better because your position is
just really overwhelmingly good here
so after castles uh we're on move 15 and
i'm going to show you a nice little
sequence that uh basically wins wins
your opponent's queen by by force here
so let's try
and and follow the path here
so how can we get after our opponent's
king and force our opponent to to
sacrifice some material
what ideas do you guys have
yeah rook b4 is the first move that is
really going to stick out to you
who else has some ideas
any other ideas is there something with
e4
yeah e4 also looks very very nasty
and uh yeah so far you guys are the best
i think both those moves win
it's not the move i'm going to recommend
though the move that i'm going to
recommend is very forcing and it gets
you there very quickly
well actually
not too quickly but it's forcing so that
ev every move sort of comes naturally
um there's one more path we could take
that on the surface looks like it might
be a little bit of a slower way to come
after your opponent
yeah okay we could go h5
um
i'm not so concerned so h5 is kind of a
funny move um in general when your
opponent has a pawn on g2 or g3 h5 is a
really great idea because you can go h5
h4 and then maybe someday you get to
take your opponent's g pawn and then
they won't have a g pawn anymore
uh in this case we already took our
opponent's g pawn which is why they're
dead lost so h5 doesn't actually make
quite as much sense here because we
already sort of achieved the point of h5
without having to do it and this is why
the grab is a bad opening
um the idea i'm fishing for is to
actually sort of just weasel our rook
over here along this sixth rank and this
turns out i think to be the simplest way
to win the game
so i think the computer is going to say
that's uh rook b4 no it's going to say
that e4 is the best of these options
just to give you a little taste of what
this looks like e4
um this is horrendous for white going
back to e1 we're just gonna come out
like this and this and the game is over
so white has to go for this little
tactic here
and then i think the engine wants to
take on f3
take on e2
and
uh basically just just win this position
i think you can go rookie eight and you
go this way it looks looks very very
strong
so e4 good idea rook b4 also a good idea
i think at this point white has to play
uh i think d4 is white's best best
option here
and
again things are gonna get a little bit
a little bit tough for for white maybe
i'm misremembering what is what is
white's best option after this one yeah
i go d4
yeah i had it all right and then a3
and then that momentarily displaces my
rook black is still going to be better
but it's actually not quite so easy to
get this rook uh to swing across here
with this sort of clogged up center and
white's control over the g5 square still
so i like this move knight c5 that the
engine is
uh not saying is the the top move but
but one of the top moves um and i like
it because again it's very very forcing
and now black is gonna win in the same
way against pretty much everything if
you try the move e4 i'm just gonna take
it
and now you have nothing defending any
of the light squares around your king
and i think the same plane here rook b6
move the bishop rook g6 is gonna gonna
end your game especially since you don't
have any control over f3 my bishop can
retreat be on the long diagonal i'm
gonna win
so that is to say white is basically
forced to retreat this bishop and the
good news is it doesn't really matter
where he goes we're gonna do the same
thing we're gonna jump in with knight e4
misplace this uh this queen for white a
little bit more uh put it back on g2
now we're going to play queen to c8
with a very
uh simple idea we want to go bishop h3
force queen h1 maybe even take a rook
but maybe not take a rook maybe just
leave your bishop there
um white really only has one choice
against this white needs to try this
move knight to e1
point being if you do this i can take
your knight so knight e1 the point is to
give this queen
a square to breathe on
um if you don't play 91 if you play
something like rook d1 rook e1 for
example i will go bishop h3 and now
after queen to h1 like
you might as well
might as well resign i think rook b4
works here i think rook b6 also oh queen
g4 is made in two good call good call
um so yeah you absolutely have to play
91.
so now knight e1 has successfully
stopped our idea of bishop h3 but not to
worry now we are just going to go rook
b6 and
moving the bishop out of the way pretty
much to any square in rip g6 is simply
unstoppable you just you cannot stop
this idea
uh just an example line d3 apparently is
best i'll move
and then here i get to throw in a nice
little idea of bishop h3 first
i think and
queen g3 rook g6 i won your queen if you
go this way
check
i'll take your rook first and then uh
i'll go on to win your queen later
probably
probably you're still gonna end up
losing your queen here unfortunately
um
so
this is how it works this is how you win
the queen there's just nothing you can
really do
uh knight to g2 for example
take the queen hg3 and now you go queen
g4
and after bishop d5 i decided to call it
quits on showing any moves because black
is just very very clearly winning here
uh you have a queen for a knight and a
rook
however none of white's pieces make any
sense you can go h5 h4 and then
checkmate white you can go queen e2
queen f3 and then try to check
you can do
any number of things here and black is
is gonna be completely winning h5h4 with
the idea of h takes g3 i think is the
cleanest but again there's there's a lot
of ways to win the game from this point
so that is my refutation to sort of the
main line of the garage that that's what
it's all about so let's take it from the
top here see if you guys can can call
out the moves as we go g4 what move are
we gonna play
yeah d5 straight to the point your pawn
is attacked uh bishop g2 now what do we
do
yeah your opponent hung upon might as
well take it
c4 our opponent wants to come after us
what's the most natural idea
c6 we want to cut off the bishop and
defend our light squares now we're
looking at c takes d5 c takes d5 queen
to b3 now which pawn do we care about
yeah we care about the d-pawn so knight
f6 to defend the pawn remembering we
want to keep this e5 option in reserve
which is why we didn't go e6 also maybe
we want to bring our bishop back
so that's another reason not to play e6
now white again
sort of has to take this pawn otherwise
he's down a pawn for nothing
so queen b7 this move's obvious we have
to defend the rook and uh developer
knight so we go knight d7
knight c3
and now how do we
uh approach the position here this is
our first moment where we need to sort
of settle down and remember what to do
so i think e5 is a good move but it's
not the move i want to play so i want to
distract this queen first
yeah we go rook b8 first
now queen a7
and of course now your move
e5
um
and i showed you the idea with my arrow
but don't worry about it
um so knight takes d5 what else from
white what else are we going to do
otherwise black has all the same ideas
and also a d5 pawn so white's going to
capture now of course we want to take
this knight
and what's the follow-up
yeah we go bishop c5 developing with
tempo against the queen white goes queen
to a4 making a threat so how do we deal
with it
just retreat
knight f3
yeah
nice and simple castle and this move of
course also makes a threats our threat
is knight b6 so white goes queen h4
do we want to trade queens
of course not bishop e7 with tempo
keeping the tempo moves coming
now queen to g3 attacks our pawn
so what move defends
bishop f6 we get castles
and this is where i asked you guys to
list some moves all of your moves were
very good one of them was even the best
move but it's not the move i'm
recommending what move am i recommending
yeah knight c5 taking advantage of this
bishop bishop's gonna move out of the
way
and knight e4 misplacing the queen
and finally how are we
uh
well i i said finally not quite finally
so we can misplace white's pieces even
further
yeah queen d7 i think works just as well
but i like queens of c8 um
the only reason being maybe there's
one or two lines where white tries to
escape with this and gets a tempo on our
queen if we go to d7
so queen c8 instead white must play
knight e1
and now of course the the finishing
touch
yeah rook to b6 we move the bishop we
play rook g6 and the game ends
and there you go that's how you refute
the grub takes 18 moves most of them are
not too unnatural they all have some
logical flow to them you remember a
couple key ideas it's rook b8 idea this
e5 idea and you're gonna do very very
well again if you happen to mess it up
along the way it's not like you're in
big danger black is going to be at least
a little bit better in
pretty much every move i i thought to
play in these positions
so rook b6 just show one more time i
showed the move d3 bishop e7 takes
bishop h3
and rook g6 in order to to win the game
here
now i didn't show
this line actually now that i'm looking
at it so let's see what happens if white
tries queen
to f3
is this where i'm looking
i don't think this is where i was
looking at it
uh ah i was looking here so d e4 bishop
h3 what happens if white tries queen to
f
no d e4
oh i see okay so d3 bishop e7 i thought
it was worth mentioning what happens if
white tries queen to f3 here the point
being it removes the queen from the
threat of rip to g6 now that this has
been introduced
but here you also win via very simple
means you give check the king has to
move if you go knight to g2 we go bishop
h3
very strong so king to h1 and then our
knights attacked and it turns out in
this case it is good to just remove the
knight from the threat of capture and
then i showed a couple more moves rook
g1 bishop g4
this queen has no squares on this
diagonal so it comes back you take e2
ship g5
you're just winning you're just totally
totally winning here i think h6 is good
i think many many things are good queen
f5 is also very strong
not too hard for black but i wanted to
show one more line just to show you
white can keep the queen but this line i
think is is even worse for for white
than uh than the others
okay so any questions on this main main
line
any questions for me
okay awesome so i want to take a look
now at uh this other move that i
mentioned white has which is the move
queen to b3 so i'm going to flip over to
here
let's see we got g4 d5 of course bishop
g2 bishop g4
c4 c6 and now rather than capturing the
pawn we're going to look at queen b3 and
i kept this this one sort of short and
sweet pretty much all of the main ideas
we've already been introduced to here
they all revolve around sort of
attacking this queen on b7 and getting a
very very dominant position from it and
i didn't go quite as in depth into the
ensuing attack you kind of saw
how how that goes so queen to b3 and in
this case rather than knight f6 which is
their move to defend the d-pawn
previously we are actually going to play
this move e6 in this position
and i will show y in just a moment so
white of course should capture on b7
um i will say at any moment white can
insert c takes d5 it doesn't really
matter but it's going to be played later
and our response is always the same so
let's see queen b7
now of course it's the same dilemma as
before so we are going to play
uh knight to d7
now knight to c3 it's starting to look
like we might transpose uh but again
white hasn't committed to this yet so we
don't really want to play knight f6
because now white might actually be
interested in capturing our c6 pawn so
instead we're going to go knight to e7
point being we're defending our c6 pawn
now after c takes d5 we're actually
gonna take with the e pawn and like i
said white could insert this move sort
of at any moment but our response is
pretty much always going to be the same
in this line we just want to go e takes
d5 the point being that is going to keep
this bishop bad and that's actually
going to keep this knight from harassing
us you know we saw this knight takes d5
line move in our main line here we can
actually just avoid all those
complications with this queen b3 line
uh so that's the main point uh after
queen b3 we're going to go e6
then we develop like normally and the
difference here is we want to bring this
knight to e7 to keep this pawn on c6 to
keep white's pieces out so cd5 ed5
what else for white here aside from d4
trying to get developed
and now the good news for us is the
ideas are again very very similar to
what they were uh previously we just
want to go rook to b8 harass white's
queen and this is how we're gonna try to
win the game
uh so here the best move is queen to a6
i think after
queen to a7 you
do lose in horrible fashion although
i'm forgetting why live in the lecture
so it's probably worth taking a look at
uh let's just cheat
okay you can go knight f5 i feel like
that's not the best you can do
i feel like the computer doesn't
remember
yeah this queen c8 move is what i wanted
to give uh yeah it's it's super simple
uh the point is queen to c8 told you
guys to remember this idea because it
comes up a lot the point is now if you
try to develop your pieces we go rook to
a8 trapping the queen
and in this line if bishop to f4 we're
gonna keep it simple and actually take
on b2 and now of course uh white is
going to be on the worst end of of this
position black is again significantly
better the idea is to go knight g6
bishop b4 and win
pretty simple pretty simple idea for
what for black here and a very very
strong idea just for example let's say
knight f3 knight g6 if you go back this
way i think it might just already be
close to over for you after after bishop
to b4 the very least we're just going to
castle black is miles and miles and
miles ahead
uh by the way material here is
even for for black so you get all of
this
material is even white has you know
nothing to show for it
okay so that is the line after queen a7
uh the main move i wanted to look at is
queen a6 it puts up a little bit more
resistance uh and here we're just going
to go with rook to b6 forcing white to
continue the the track backwards i think
now after queen a7 we can transpose
with this line
uh rook to a6 just as strong of a threat
as rook to a8 so bishop f4 and we end up
in the same spot
so rook to b6 if white doesn't want to
play that and they're going to go back
to d3 and now we just develop very
simply we go knight g6 h3 we bring the
bishop back knight f3 window developer
bishop out to d6
h4
castles black has completed harmonious
development
white's king is in the center because it
makes very little sense to castle after
you don't have a g pawn and white again
has no plan no real ideas
and and black is just very very much
significantly better
just to show you
h5 looks like it makes the threat now
thanks to the lack of a g3 pawn we just
plant our knight onto f4
and for example takes takes e3 bishop
back uh this is where i decided to stop
playing moves because white is just
positionally because it's positionally
getting destroyed here you know two
bishops this bishop's a monster this
file is really good for black and white
has no attack there's nothing going on
here
so again we sped through this queen b3
line a little bit more quickly but
that's because the ideas are are largely
the same and you just end up in in this
monster position unfortunately no i
didn't continue this out until we won a
queen by force but this position is
still pretty good
uh so so questions on this because i did
go a lot faster here and then we'll do
that quick little review again just to
get it in your mind
questions here
okay
oh and hello to show in the chat who
one of his games made an appearance in
an earlier lecture for me
uh and yeah he is uh correct in saying
the trick to facing the grab more is to
play the right opponents um and that's
why this lecture is a call out of jacob
sanders okay let's take it from the top
then g4 of course we go d5 bishop g2 we
want to snag that pawn
c4 we're gonna play c6 stunting the
bishop
queen b3 e6
uh again we're not going knight f6 in
this case because white has not yet
committed to this capture so we're more
interested in keeping our c6 pawn in
these lines
now we're looking at queen b7 knight d7
knight c3 and now we want to go knight
e7 defending our pawn cd5 of course we
want ed5 in this case
point being we want to keep this knight
out and keep this bishop bad
now d4
is the best developing move for white
and we just follow it up with rook b8
queen a6 rook b6
and now we just finished her development
very naturally
castle
and go knight f4 and white is in big big
trouble
there's the moves take take e3 back
white resigns easy peasy
um okay
so aside from that there's one line that
i think i did want to mention that i
didn't have time to import
so after knight to c3 we are defending
our c6 pawn with knight e7 but for one
turn only white can capture here of
course though this is not going to be a
very good idea we're just going to go
rook c8
and rook c4
and knight f6
and in this position um again material
is even and
black controls the center
black has easy development and is way
ahead in development and white has a
bishop on c1 and the knight on g1 and a
king on e1 and no no g pawn
so black again just just close to
winning very very simply in this line
um so okay once more any questions here
okay
easy peasy then so with that i think
that you guys have enough information to
beat 90 percent of all grab players most
groud players they don't play the grub
to play h3 or e3 or some other nonsense
after d5
they're playing the grab to go bishop g2
and c4 and hope you're not prepared
um but now you guys are so you can just
win by force against ninety percent of
groud players
now with that i want to go into
what i call h3
the sad lines because they are
very very sad for for white
so uh jacob actually has a book called
the killer grob which is kind of a funny
book because it recommends g4 and
against d5
it recommends h3 so
not very true to the spirit of the
opening i would say uh is the the killer
graph book because h3 is not very killer
it's very sad um
just for example here imagine that you
were forced like someone forced you to
play the move one h3 on turn one and
your opponent responded with d5
think of how many other moves you would
want to play before you you wanted to
play the move g4 like d4 is a better
move d3 e3 knight f3 is a better move c4
is a better move c3 is a better move b3
is a better move
g3 is a better move
so it's sort of playing one bad move
then your opponent strikes in the center
and just to avoid losing a pawn you play
a second bad move so now white is
basically down
to full tempe because h3 g4 are nonsense
moves that don't help the position and
d5
now second move you guessed it e5 are
two great moves that control the center
and give black a huge advantage
so that's why these h3 lines are just
very very sad sad for white
um bishop g2 to follow up and here again
you can do anything you want you can go
97 i think you can go knight f6 bishop
b6 c6
um
probably bishop e7 or c5 but i i don't
know about all of those most of those
i'm sure give black a very easy
advantage c6 notably is again a very
logical move and a very good move
similar to our other lines but here i'm
actually going to recommend the move
knight to c6 just because it gets
ourselves developed a little bit faster
puts the pressure on white a little bit
more quickly now knight to c3 does
attack our pawn and here i like this
move knight g to e7
now why would i want to be putting my
knight on e7
against a pawn on g4 what do you think
the long term idea is against this
so there's sort of two things to look
out for i mean f4 would be an awesome
outpost yeah
exactly so by moving this pawn to g4 you
have permanently weakened your f4 square
and so maybe one day i'll want to go
knight g6 to f4 maybe even knight g6 to
h4 to be honest depending on what
happens
uh and aside from that there's one more
big idea
which
is a very useful one to know
so f5 is sort of almost justifying g4 in
my opinion so
i'm not going to lie to you and say that
black is going to be worse after f5
because it's very very difficult to do
against the grab
but you're on the right track but not
with f5 how do we want to attack this
this pawn
it's just a better a better version of
f5 basically
yeah you just go h5
um so after e3 that is actually the move
that i recommend here we just go h5
now uh because our knight isn't on f6
our opponent can't play g5 with tempo
uh
and
so they still probably need to play g5
because this is actually very very bad
for white if you allow takes and takes
because we simply get to the king side
first
so if you go g5 now my knight makes a
lot more sense because i have easy
access to these squares now i don't know
which one i'm going to choose yet but
better than f on f6 for sure
now development's still very easy for
black go bishop e6 over defending our
pawn freeing up our knight a little bit
now d4
and here we're just going to shore up
our center with f6
now just as an example line i really you
can stop here black's play is going to
be easy
pretty much against everything you want
to go queen d7 queen side castles pick a
square for your knight develop your
bishop somewhere and you're going to be
much much much better
but as my example line i wanted to show
gf6 gf6 queen e2 queen d7 uh de5 fe-5
for example bishop d2 castle's castles
and i i went ahead and stopped here
because i think it is again already like
minus minus four or something really
really crazy
um you can play knight f5 here looking
at these weak squares looking at d4
you can play rook g8 here hitting this
bishop you can play e4 here opening up
this diagonal shutting down this bishop
you can do many many things and be much
much much better so
our goal of the opening has been
achieved we got like a minus four
position against the crop
and thus these are in fact the sad lines
so one more time how did we get here
g4d5
instead of bishop g2 white decided to
grovel with h3 defending the pawn now we
just take over the center very quickly
with e5 knight c6 we do this clever move
knight g to e7 with the idea of h5
forcing weaknesses from our opponent
then we just finish our development very
naturally defend our center queen d7
and queen side castles and that's that's
really all you need to know from here
you just play chess
and just to prove it let's let's ask the
computer uh minus 3.6 king b2 is -2.5
rick g8 is minus 3.6
and it's just it's just horrible it's
horrible horrible horrible for black
okay
so with that i want to take a quick look
at the only other moves that have ever
been played in the master database after
g4 d5 uh and after that this is about as
thorough as you can get against the grub
this is going to be every move pretty
much you can reasonably expect to face
so g4 d5 there is one more move worth
playing for white which is e3
obviously this move defends the pawn on
g4 and actually seems to make more sense
than the move h3 right it is controlling
the center somewhere
the good news is you can respond to this
in nearly an identical
nearly an identical manner we're going
to go e5 controlling the center
bishop g2
our move is the exact same we want to go
knight c6 now knight to c3 we're gonna
defend our pawn with bishop to e6 this
time i think knight to g to e7 is still
a very very good move
uh but we'll see why we wanted to leave
the knight back in this line in a little
bit
uh and after d4 here i'm going to
recommend the move e4 the reason being
you can sort of imagine this as a french
defense like white is playing you know
the typical black side of the french
defense here
where knight to c3 has been played
seemingly for no reason remember in the
french you would love to play the move
c4 can't do that with the knight on c3
and on top of that
you've brought your bishop to g2 also
for some strange reason and also you put
your pawn on g4 also for some very very
very strange reason so these are three
things that nobody ever does in the
french and here white has done all of
them which is why he has a borderline
losing position
just to show you the the main line here
queen to e2 we go bishop e7
h3
h5
and the reason we left our knight on g8
is because in this line
white has opened up the queen's path to
the g pawn which makes g takes h5 a very
reasonable move here we obviously can't
recapture but now our knight is going to
come in to save the day with knight to
f6
so that's why we wanted the knight on g8
rather than e7 so we could come to f6
after this line and recapture our pawn
on h5
now i did put in some more moves here
just uh you want to do the same thing as
last time basically move your queen up
and castle d7 and d6 are both great
squares
h4 castles knight b5 for example you
just retreat
and here
black's play is is pretty simple you
want to go f5 think about this move f4
attack down this h file uh against this
weak pawn and use your your massive
center to to crush your opponent and and
win win when easily
and so that is this move e3 i think i
put in a few more moves knight e2 a6
king b8
f3 and here again there's any number of
moves that that you can play with with
black uh including nothing and you will
be doing
very very very well in this position
okay so any questions on that move e3
okay one more time how we got here
white plays e3 defending the pawn we
take over the center same as last time
knight c6 same as last time bishop e6 in
this case and against d4 we are closing
the position forcing white to play a
horrible horrible french now after queen
e2 our idea is to target this h5 pawn
like this making use of our knight on g8
we come f6 to h5 and then we want a
queen side castle
and expand on the king's side with f5
there you go
all right there's one more final move i
want to take a look at with the last few
remaining minutes and that is g4 d5 g5
um so are you familiar with this move
do you play this move
sometimes okay so g5 is the last one i
want to take a look at um i believe
um
a second jacob in the chess club uh
jacob wilkins uh
has been quoted to me as saying you know
i i don't like playing the the grub but
if i've been forced to play the grub i
would play 2g5
so there you go jacob wilkins seal of
approval this move g5 uh kind of
so
it shouldn't be too hard to to guess
what we want to do against this move
we want to control the center and
somehow target target this pawn
so
wait a second i actually kept both lines
in here okay i think the one that i
wanted to recommend is this move e5 you
know same as last time we are staying
consistent want to go e5 and control the
center
now white in this case
his idea might be to strike back
directly in the center with d4 trying to
do something like e3 control the center
and defend the pawn with d4
unfortunately here you are going to end
up in a pretty bad way after e takes d4
um for example what happens if queen
takes
d4
i believe here we can do any number of
things
but
i'm going to go ahead and say that c5 is
is just very very strong we're just
going to develop your pieces
check me i'm going to go here
go knight c6 bishop f5 i own the center
i am not down any pawns you have a pawn
on g5 for no reason at all and black is
much better
so white's best attempt is to try to
take this pawn back with a knight but
now we're just gonna go c5
and after c3 we simply go dc3 and now
knight c3
and here i just want to recommend the
move d4 just to keep everything solid of
course this was under threat so we go d4
white moves out of the way and now we
just finish our development very easily
with bishop g2 or we're starting with
knight c6
and then finally the uh
point where i chose to stop here is the
point where we finally do something
about this g5 pawn you can just let it
sit here but it turns out that white's
has actually made our development
slightly awkward right we obviously
can't develop this knight h6 or f6 and
if we go to e7 uh
white's might be able to take this pawn
can white even just not take this pawn
is there just queen a5 here i just
assumed the point was that white could
take this pawn but maybe white can't
even take this pawn this opening is is
bad in new and exciting ways all the
time um yeah so okay you can also play
knight e7 here i thought you couldn't
but instead i recommended the best move
h6
again hard to be worse against the grub
but
you might manage it if you don't know
so h6 is i think the best move the point
being we just want to get rid of this
this pawn and and continue our
development a little bit more naturally
now if white wants to play uh the
annoying move g6
this looks at first glance a little bit
scary it's gonna break open our king but
it turns out you can take this and then
you're up two pawns which is really
really good
um we'll actually just up one pawn but
still it's a really really good pawn
and if
black wants to play or white wants to
play something else
um i don't even think i bothered to
input other moves no i did put in
castles uh and here
yeah there's a number of things you can
do i think
simply bishop e7 is is what i wanted to
recommend now you are forcing white's
hand still has to go to g6 you still can
just take this be up a clean pawn
control the center and be
in a winning position
so with that that is pretty much every
line i could think of for white that's
every line that's been tried in the
master's database people have done other
stupid things in the leaches database
but they're all even worse than the
lines that you've seen here today which
is sort of impressive
um so i think the last thing i want to
show as someone great wolf in the chat
has mentioned um why not f3 trying to
blender mate in one this is actually
something that i've played with white
when i'm trying to just like do
something dumb and fast and bullet of
course though our plan is going to be
the same we want to go e5 knight c6 and
just play play to win the f3 pawn is not
going to change our plans and in fact is
only going to make white's position
worse okay
so any final questions for me on the
grab ah no no you you fell for the trick
bishop g2
you can't actually snag this king so
this is why i played in bullet you know
opponent's queen comes out to h4 maybe
they'll hang it maybe they they miss
something um but uh it i mean black is
winning here it's like minus three minus
yeah it's minus three
so pretty good pretty good for black
okay any final questions for me on the
grab before we call tonight here
would you recommend playing
i would not recommend playing the grub
good question though good question
anything else
any burning questions you guys have had
about the grab for years that you know
you want you want to get answered now
okay well fair enough thank you all so
much for joining me here my apologies to
jacob sanders for showing all the
refutation refutations to his opening uh
hopefully he can still get away with it
sometimes but if you are a kid in st
louis and jacob's beating you up with
the grub now now you know come watch
this video this is this is what they
need
um okay with that please stick around
guys we've got grandmaster romaine
edward coming in to teach a lecture
right after this it's going to be
awesome
but as always i want to thank you all
very much for joining me here on the
road to 2000 my name is caleb denby
and i will see you all next time
[Music]
you